a la calma el presidente estadounidense
Joe biden reiteró la seguridad del
sistema bancario y confirmó que gracias
a la rápida acción gubernamental los
clientes del silicon Valley Bank que
quebró la semana pasada tendrán
asegurado su dinero todos los clientes
que tenían sus depósitos en estos bancos
pueden estar tranquilos seguros de que
estarán protegidos y que tendrán acceso
a su dinero desde hoy la subida de las
tasas de interés llevó a que los
clientes del banco en su mayoría
startups y empresas tecnológicas
decidieran no endeudarse optaron por
hacer uso de sus dineros retirando
grandes sumas de manera muy veloz el
banco había adquirido bonos del tesoro
hace tiempo estas inversiones son
conocidas por su estabilidad pero
presionados por cumplir con las demandas
de sus clientes el cbd tuvo que
venderlos a un precio más bajo lo que
conllevó a una pérdida de 1800 millones
de dólares luego el cbb fracasó en una
emisión de acciones con la que buscaba
recolectar más de 2.000 millones de
dólares esto causó grandes confianzas
sobre la salud financiera de la entidad
derivando en una corrida bancaria Fue
entonces cuando el gobierno de biden
decidió intervenir a pesar de la rápida
respuesta del gobierno de biden los
temores de contagio se extendieron a
otras latitudes
no vemos un riesgo específico de
contagio contaction
Por supuesto que estamos monitoreando la
situación en estrecho contacto con el
Banco Central europeo
tomamos nota de la iniciativa adoptada
por las autoridades estadounidenses para
evitar un contagio en Estados Unidos
el banco signature también entró en
quiebra y el miedo a una posible
afectación a bancos pequeños o medianos
es latente la situación también tiene
efectos en monedas como el peso mexicano
y el colombiano que cotizan a la baja